[Music]
we're gonna go to the phones we've got
summer in scottsdale arizona summer
welcome to the ramsey show
hi can you go hear me okay yes how you
doing how can we help hi um hi this is
exciting i've never been on the ramsay
show so
we're just as excited
uh i just had a quick question so um i
have two jobs right now i have a day job
i'm a loan officer associate for a bank
and then at night um i work in bars in
old town scottsdale
and because
i can
save i have the ability to say that i do
save um
between 40 and 60 of my net income um
every month
so but i do have some student loan debt
and also i owe a little bit of money on
my car
so i was wondering if my i plan on
paying off my car this month um and
that'll just be gone um but i have about
thirty two thousand dollars in student
loan debt
but my interest rate on my student loan
debt is very very very low about less
than two percent so i was just wondering
if you think it would be stupid of me to
put about 25 of my income towards my
student loan and then 25 percent just
into like a cash savings account
investing or whatever
um what i'm hearing is you're wanting to
do a few things at once you're wanting
to pay off the debt but you're also
wanting to stack up some savings and
what i recommend is focusing on one
thing at a time and that's what we teach
in the baby steps and so we teach to
start with that thousand dollar savings
which it sounds like you have right now
you've got a thousand dollars in cash
right
yeah and once you have that what you
want to do is list out your debts from
smallest to largest which which it
sounds like the car loan is the smallest
debt you have right now
and that'll be gone this month and
that'll be gone this month which means
we're really focusing on the student
loan and so what i want you to do there
is stop saving right now stop uh sucking
away that cash do you have more cash
other than a thousand dollars
oh yeah i have about um fourteen
thousand dollars in cash right now after
my car's payoff there we go and that's
aside from the thousand dollar emergency
fund or is that all lumped in there um
no about 13 and so 14 total so uh
so if i'm you what i'm doing is taking
13 000 and slapping it on the student
loan getting rid of that and putting the
rest on the car and that's going to take
down that car loan to what 20 grand
maybe
under 24. the car will be gone after the
cars paid off i have 13 000 in cash
fantastic so that means you're down to
uh 19
19 000 on the car and with all this
extra income that's getting money no
she's not obsessed she keeps saying the
car is gone so after the car now she now
she can slap 32 000 in the student loan
and you have 13 you can throw on that
that's huge which would bring that down
to 19. uh total on the student loan and
with this extra income that you have
coming in which is fantastic that you're
you can save all that instead of putting
it in savings i want you to attack that
debt uh so that you can be debt free my
guess is within a few months at this
rate is that possible yeah
um probably about yeah i make about six
thousand a month usually so if i put
three thousand towards debt
um that was hard yeah about six months
yeah if you've got 19 left that's about
six months that's fantastic summer what
a game changer that is in your life i
want you to just soak on that for a
moment how would that feel
pretty good
yeah what's great ken is that she's
she's got the discipline down the work
ethic is there yeah
you're just trying to do multiple things
at once and what i want is for you to
feel the progress of seeing this debt
gone so that you free up the payment
from the car loan the payment that
you're making towards that student loan
and we don't really we don't care about
interest rate what we care about is
getting the biggest
wealth building tool back in your life
which is your income momentum summer do
you see what george is telling you this
is gets you the most momentum and it
just powers you through this
so yeah thank you guys so much yeah you
bet you're impressive call us back when
you're dead free i'd love to hear the
debt-free scream on this one yeah she's
busting it too sacrificing getting after
it hear that she's at my day job and
then i'm working the bars down in old
town scottsdale and she's not scared to
work and that that is the number one
indicator that you're going to be able
to get out of this debt no question
about that i love it